some of the most exciting and valuable
entrepreneurial opportunities are based
on innovations that combine ideas from
existing product categories what I'm
interested in is trying to understand
what are the advantages of being an
established firm from one of those
established product categories in those
kinds of innovations versus the
advantages of being a startup consumers
and buyers bring to the market they're
established understandings of existing
products and those understandings serve
as lenses through which they interpret
new products it is the way in which they
make sense of those new products so on
the one hand in many settings
established firms might have an
advantage because their association with
an established product makes it easier
for consumers to understand what the new
product and the innovation does
another settings startups might have an
advantage in part that's because they
don't have an existing identity to
create confusion because sometimes what
happens is that the new product is
sufficiently different from the existing
products that if you try to interpret it
through the existing product lenses
you're gonna misunderstand and you're
not gonna see the potential of the
product when established firms are
trying to move into a new market so for
example they come up with a new
innovation in their labs they face a
challenge which is consumers already
associate us with our existing products
and so how do we now think about getting
them to understand the product that
we're offering given that they're going
to understand the product that we're
offering through the lens or through the
category that they already associate
with us as a producer so if I'm like on
and I produce a digital camera people
are going to understand the digital
camera in terms of their understanding
of me as a producer of film cameras so
what they're going to bring to bear on
that is how does a film camera work what
does it do for me and is that a virtue
or a liability in terms of their ability
to understand my product as a digital
camera if I'm night on it's probably an
advantage and in fact that's what my
research shows it is an advantage but if
I am HP it's actually a disadvantage
right because when you on HP you look at
me and you think computer and if you
think of computer well there's a digital
camera really do what a computer does
one of the mistakes I think that a lot
of entrepreneurial firms make in that
kind of situation is they make appeals
to a lot of different product categories
at the same time so they say our product
is a little bit like this and it's a
little bit like that and it's a little
bit like that it combines the best
elements of all these different kinds of
things together what the research shows
though is that when you combine lots of
different elements from lots of
different categories together what it
creates in the mind of the buyer or the
consumer is confusion and when they get
confused they ignore you and so it can
be a problem for an entrepreneur to have
this kind of confused identity when in
fact it could be an advantage to have a
much more crisp and clear identity going
into the market the problem with that of
course is that you don't know ahead of
time necessarily which identity is going
to be the best so this is an important
element of an entrepreneurial strategy
is you have to make a bet on which
identity do you think is going to be the
one that's going to be best able to help
consumers make sense of the product that
you're bringing to market